foreign
comes from Brenda in Missouri my husband
and I are 61 and we had a nice Nest Egg
of Investments we worked with our
financial advisor for 14 years and he
was someone that we trusted that was
trusted and did Financial seminars at
our church he ended up embezzling all of
our retirement Investments oh gosh and
is now in prison but we're left with
nothing what should we do we're scared
death oh Brenda oh
well I'm going to assume there's there's
lawsuits and you know action that's
being taken
um
yeah the only thing I can think of is
the two examples that come to mind are
one again this is third hand but reading
some of the Bernie Madoff losses right
um and they were left with nothing and
they had to start over and then the
people that I knew in Houston where I
grew up that were overly if not entirely
invested in Enron and Enron went away
and they woke up and went to bed
millionaires they woke up next day with
nothing with nothing and they literally
had to start over and um just had to go
get
a close friend family that who I
actually love was uh executive there and
then shortly thereafter was um running a
laser tag company I mean and was going
to massage school I mean just started
over like we got to start over so
um
this is one of those hard things that
maybe you can have a loss well well I
don't yeah I don't know it's insured but
I doubt it
if you contact you know who he was Whose
license was with I mean like you know
what I mean sometimes that there's some
insurance or something yes some things
in there within yeah I mean I would dig
into that Brenda but man
just to tell you to start over at 61
breaks my heart it does it does
um
yeah it breaks my heart and there is
unfortunately my career has been
the the majority of my career has been
sitting down with folks when the worst
of the worst has happened and saying
okay this is this is reality this is
this is what has happened what are we
going to do next yeah right yeah and it
would it's maybe a hard conversation
about we got to go back to work and both
of us gonna have to work a lot just to
try to get a little bit back in the as
much as we can back in the system so
that it can start earning and start
earning yeah
um and now's a tough season
um actually now's a great season to be
throwing money in the market because
it's on sale right but
um
if this is what I think it is Brenda I I
hate to be the guy to tell you but it
looks like y'all are going to be
starting over and it may be what you
thought were the next 20 years between
61 and 81 y'all are going to be
traveling the country it may be between
61 81 y'all are working really hard um
we are finding work in your local
community or maybe have to move you've
got to figure stuff out
um not by your hand but in your lap this
happened and
we're gonna have to call some old
business contacts we're gonna have to
crank up a small business we're gonna
have to get a job in a local community
and
um
to start safe and again this is just
really heartbreaking Rachel do you have
any other
yeah no I mean that would be it I would
either go you know the legal routes and
see what again where licenses are where
he's Affiliated I mean talking to
all that but if there's not a safety net
there
and a catch-all and uh yeah anything
there than starting over is is what that
would be the case that's like yeah so
what do we do now with that reality so
I'm so sorry Brenda